hi everyone my name is Tamara chambers
and this is Tamara's never seen and
today I am watching Jurassic Park - last
world my second ever episode for Tamra's
never seen was Jurassic Park the first
one I've seen the third one multiple
times that's always the one that's on TV
and I watched as a kid a few times I
love it I love that he baits him with P
remember that that gem in the film I'm
wearing a red wig because Julianne
Moore's in this movie and I love her I
didn't know she was in the movie until I
was like watching the movie I was like
aha
there's Julianne Moore so you it's a
good story Tamara it's kind of fun to
follow up that second episode so long
ago with the second Jurassic Park
I clearly am a fan of the first Jurassic
Park it's a masterful work of art let's
get into it
[Music]
well that was disappointing
where was the magic where was the flair
and the fun okay well Jeff Goldblum
wasn't it a lot so I loved certain
aspects I've had certain scenes were
really really cool then they would be
ruined by like a 90s like weird trope
there's this really cool scene where
actors are coming in on Julianne Moore
and Jeff Goldblum and his daughter and
and you're like oh man how are they
gonna get out of this crazy scenario and
then his daughter dusts and gymnastics
thankfully there were parallel bars in
the middle of this industrial shed that
they were in I did gymnastics for nine
years and I never did anything
interesting I want a medal once bronze
anyways it opens on a family who's at
Jurassic Park or they're at site B of
Jurassic Park why where are they and why
are they there and why are there they're
dinosaurs where they're at so they're at
this beach and they're rich they're
doing the whole rich family thing the
mom is such a stereotype of rich mothers
it's hilarious she's like darling don't
go too far the snakes around like happy
darling
don't eat that sandwich really you'll
ruin your supper yo your appetite for
prawns your favorite prawns no
six-year-old likes prawns lady get it
together Deidre then pour a little Kathy
died from the dinosaurs so her mom was
you know at least correct and thinking
that reptiles were dangerous you're Jeff
Goldblum go throughout the film warmed
my heart it's such an odd way which he's
just prone to do he's so weird in his
acting and so overdramatic but it still
feels real he's just he's very good he
says these hilarious lines and he takes
so much time a thing that a lot of
directors will say is take the air out
of it like if you're you're really
milking it for like some feeling it's
like that's not real people don't like
milk things for feeling when they're
saying just a normal like go get the
bread there they say go get the bread
they don't say go
get the bread every line he says is like
that and it's like take the air out
buddy but for some reason it works for
him and it's fascinating to watch and I
just wrote Oh Vince Vaughn whoa I just
don't believe Vince Vaughn ever yeah he
I'm sure is a good actor
that I've just failed to see he's a
good-looking guy he gets some great
roles this one I especially did not
believe that
so you see Vince Vaughn and Jeff
Goldblum and some other guy make it to
site B then you see Julianne Moore is
the girlfriend the new girlfriend of
Jeff Goldblum and also his daughter has
stowed away because it's a nineties film
that just makes sense then a bunch of
ass wipes show up to take some of the
dinosaurs back to the mainland for
profit and it makes no sense it makes no
goddamn sense why are you gonna go and
take dinosaurs back to America San Diego
a highly populated city you know it's
not gonna turn that well you're just a
stupid little manchild you're not gonna
be able to control it t-rex are you
joking me that's fine
use all the horse tranquilizers
tranquilizers Trinculo use all the horse
tranquilizers you want use all the
restraints you want we've been learning
about dinosaurs since kindergarten we
were kindergartners learn about dinos
there's stressful it means are big and
bad you don't mess with them it's very
easy concept to grasp this movie could
just like ended because people use their
noggins the biggest that's why we have
film all right
rant over there's a really long scene
where these t-rex multiple t-rexes are
pushing off a car that three of the
characters are in off of a cliff and
it's a very it's cool and it's it looks
great
and you get to see very up close shots
of a puppet like animatronic t-rex head
that they use a lot throughout the film
but it just goes on a really long time
there's a couple scenes that it's just
like okay yes we get it
so then the t-rex is chasing them all
because basically the entire film was
just t-rexes and Raptors chasing humans
and it's turned away from like this
really cool like sciency feeling movie
like wow there's dinosaurs and all this
majesticness and to just like you know a
monster film kind of it felt like even
at the end you got very Godzilla yeah it
was weird
so the whole movie is just kinda like a
monster movie anyways a t-rex is chasing
them all and they're like face to face
with the t-rex and Vince Vaughn just
yells you shut up a bitch the cool it's
absolutely gonna solve your problem
Vince Vaughn
you idiots but again some really cool
visuals the resisting where they're all
running through tall grass and the
Raptors are just at grass height level
and so you see them running through and
it looks super cool it goes into the
scene I was talking about earlier with
the gymnastics which is so cool until
the gymnastics showed up and then it
became like your kitschy 90s movie and
and so it's really cool aspects that
just were routed there's so many plot
holes because the story is just poorly
written so many gaping hope mmm not
gonna say that it's Christmas no one is
checking in on that like they've been to
Jurassic Park before like everyone knows
that the dinosaurs are dangerous and
that they're there with Dinosaurs don't
you think every hour they would be like
checking in on them also they were on
like basically a Skype call and a giant
dinosaur rammed through their tent and
like the people who were back home saw
that no one's gonna be like maybe though
maybe we will send in some help or like
maybe just send him like a little text I
know texting didn't exist
I realized that you know amongst the
craziness probably communication was
down but that just felt a little odd the
saddest part of the film for me though
was when the t-rex makes it eventually
to San Diego California and eats a wolf
owns a sir barks-a-lot the bark bark
dogs he eats the dogs and it makes me
sick and I hate it it's really sad I
didn't want it bad the second I saw the
dog I was like oh no that's he's gonna
eat the dog damn it I hate when dogs get
hurt in films should i watch Marley & Me
nuts
Matt Matt Matt yep yeah that's what I'm
at I'm glad I'm reading through these
and people don't seem to be completely
disagreeing with me
that's always so nice you know what I
mean you'll be sad the velociraptors
didn't form their own fabulous gymnastic
squad and challenged the daughter to a
competition I am like what I didn't know
that I was but yeah now that you say it
yes I I'm very sad about that how did
the ship's pilot get his hand a bit
enough how how how did a giant t-rex get
out of its holding cell get into that
small ass room that the captain was in
and bite off just enough for his hand
he's got a big giant hand mouth and he
just bit off the hand that's how okay
how did that happen also then he got
back into his little holding kit how did
that scene that scene didn't make sense
calm down Tamara calm down it's gonna be
okay combs down I don't up to self good
for you and I'll end it there but it's
really cool though so watch the second
one you know a year and a half after the
series started and kind of started with
Jurassic Park and it's just really cool
so thank you for still being here and
watching with me and I will see you all
next week with a magic
Oh God do a little little hair flip you
know sweet bye
[Music]
[Applause]
you